okay this is incredibly important in
maintaining an accurate understanding of
this week's protests despite claims from
Trump and his press secretary and a ton
of different right-wingers that anti feh
was doing all sorts of violence in
Washington DC at the protests this week
the FBI has found no evidence that an
Tifa was involved in the Washington DC
violence on Sunday that's the day that
the protests sort of had peak violence
or unrest they've become more and more
peaceful throughout the week now the
reason this matters is that one of the
ways that the Trump administration has
waged a propaganda war against the
overwhelmingly peaceful protesters is by
making them seem co-opted by an Tifa and
overwhelmingly violent Trump of course
even tweeting on Sunday night quote the
United States of America will be
designating an Tifa as a terrorist
organization we already talked on Monday
about the legal reality and
constitutionality of Trump doing that I
don't want to rehash that today but it
actually doesn't matter because it was a
political tool which was followed up on
on Monday with Trump saying I may send
the US military to States against
governor's wishes to further repress the
protesters who he is insisting are
overwhelmingly violent lawbreakers now
if you believe the protesters are more
violent than they are you are more
likely to support Trump's idea of
sending in the military if you believe
that violent and Tifa which again
remember there's no there's no real
thing and Tifa is more of a strategy and
an umbrella term than an organization if
you believe violent and Tifa is a
predominant factor at these protests
you're more likely to look the other way
at repression of protesters by police
well we now have documents from the
Washington FBI field office which say
very clearly as of 5:00 p.m.
based on CH s canvassing open source and
social media partner engagement and
liaison FBI Washington field office has
no intelligence indicating involvement
or presence
of auntie feh now I want to be really
really really really clear here this is
one location on one day it was claimed
that an Tifa were all over DC the FBI
found that they were not this doesn't
mean that there was no auntie for
presence anywhere clearly there was some
presence of whatever we are defining as
an Tifa the issue with all of this is
that an Tifa itself is first of all tiny
and secondly it's completely sparse in
its organization and I want to make
really crystal clear before I start
getting you the the you know the emails
and the tweets and all of it I am not
telling you that I am supportive of
auntie FFA's tactics I'm not denying
that people operating under the general
banner event if I have done violence in
the past of course they have I'm not
aware of an Tifa ever killing anybody
but there has been violence done by
people sort of purporting to be under
the umbrella of auntie feh and I am
against that the point is number one and
Tifa is more of an idea and a strategy
than it is an organization where we can
say the KKK was present here okay well
that's a much more defined group there
is a leadership structure there is
membership there are meetings bla bla
bla that is not the case with auntie feh
and that's why this is all fundamentally
a distraction the protests are mostly
peaceful
have there been bad actors of course
there have looters have looted while
protesters have protested the point is
whether or not they subscribe to the
general umbrella term of auntie feh it
lacks all organization and it doesn't
change that the bad actors are
incredibly small in number whether the
non peaceful protesters are or aren't an
Tifa is actually irrelevant here because
auntie feh is not an organization with
an established structure leadership or
the like it's a way to justify using
force against protesters it's a way to
justify Trump sending in the troops
literally and it's a way to disqualify
the activism concerns of the protesters
Tuesday night we did a livestream
looking at protests in I'm trying to
think now Boston New York City Denver DC
Atlanta
Los Angeles Columbus Ohio there were a
couple other places I don't remember
exactly there was no violence anywhere
during the two-hour stream where we were
just watching protests in all of these
places with the exception of about five
minutes in Atlanta where protesters
destroyed
you know those chain-link fences that go
around a construction site some of that
fencing was destroyed and there were
even claims that the reason that
happened is because police were
releasing tear gas and protesters had to
in order to get away from it rip down
some of that fencing that may be true or
not doesn't make it okay but the point
is we had to spend two hours to find
five minutes across eight or ten cities
of something that was short of peaceful
protesting the reason this is being done
is that Trump can't lead any other way I
told you on Monday Tuesday he doesn't
have any other tools other than
criticized the people getting the media
attention and think about how can you
deploy more shows a force later in the
program I'm going to talk to you about
Donald Trump again obsessed with tanks
starting to ask the Pentagon questions
about what sort of tanks could we deploy
as a show of force along with the
military Pentagon appears to be turning
against Trump Trump's former Secretary
of Defense Jim mattis denouncing Trump
and we're going to get to all of that
later these are really fluid dynamics in
terms of the relationships between
institutions of power where even the
Pentagon and Department of Defense not
organizations that I find to be the
epitome of altruism not organizations
where I say you can always trust the
Department of Defense even they are
saying what Trump wants is too much
remember to follow me on Twitter at D
Pakman and a quick reminder if you
regularly just consume a clip here or
there on IG TV or YouTube or Facebook we
have a daily audio podcast and I know a
lot of you prefer audio podcasts
long-form - short video clips we have a
free audio podcast you can find on
itunes stitcher spotify google play
podcasts etc make sure you're subscribed
to that for the daily show let me know
what you think about the latest with the
protests on Twitter at D
Hackman and we'll be right back